and not what you'd expect from the guy
you know I'm not one of these guys that
that you seem porn or something going at
it for hours and has on end I'm that it
took me a long time to actually say it
I find sex tricky I felt weird about sex
my whole adult life I think I think what
I want to do or maybe what I don't want
to do is sometimes exactly what I'm
expected to do in my head anyway I I
don't know if that makes sense but I
think when you're younger you just go
along with it you just try and treat it
casually but it's never really felt me I
think if there was a poem that was
designed specifically for me be called
something like shy porn or something you
know something basically porn for people
who a bit hung up about sex
my ideal porn um well the guy I think
the guy would be the guy would ask the
girl he could touch her and I think she
I mean they would like each other that
there would be the skill and this kind
of conflict and I don't know that's how
I feel about sex and I had a dad who was
really macho
I didn't really get on with him he kind
of rejected me and I suppose I rejected
him back and since then I've just been
really uncomfortable with the idea well
with you know masculine that hypehype
hours of highest turbocharged masculine
to you my mum's life was messed up by
men and maybe that's where it comes from
but for years i've struggled i I even
tried it with girls and that's fun but
didn't really feel like a solution I
think what I don't like is the loss of
control and I think I'd like to hide my
discomfort maybe but my body always
gives me away yeah and you know you
can't really sometimes shut your dick is
just isn't up for it right just isn't up
for it when we met we were both just I
think both our lowest point so that's
why we could be really honest with each
other yeah when she was the first person
I could be really totally upfront with
from the get-go if I think as you said
to you I've won sexes quite daunting and
I might get impotent and that yeah can
you imagine there's a really real
turn-on but it was and that's the thing
it was him being really honest about
something like that that made it made me
kind of open up then it was that day
actually after when we're making tea in
the kitchen and well I told you that I
suffer from vaginismus
which is a disgusting blunder but it's
basically this thing where it's when you
get too tight during sex so you know it
can make things really difficult because
nothing will go in and wide never really
told anyone that that once I did it was
like a massive weight had lifted mm-hmm
and because we could be completely
honest with each other it was very it
was very good
he's the best it ever been mm-hmm and
then we have sex all the time now and
it's probably not how most people have
sex you know we think if it has sex with
people who are a bit [ __ ] up about sex
but you know we might do something like
we might take it really slowly or we
might um just watch each other touching
or explore it was a little fishy or
something oh you've got this thing about
doing it in public places or I don't
know you like sometimes you enjoy just
one Jimmy yeah sometimes I don't enjoy
that right yeah that's probably probably
enough okay yeah basically if people
will think this sounds really weird but
it works for us
our sex book explores how sex truly
operates demonstrating that far from
thinking about sex too much we haven't
begun to think about it nearly enough